happening right now the start of the
clark county school district board
meeting trustees plan to vote on a
proposal to possibly
bring students back to campus part-time
starting in january
now a decision that kristen drummond
shows us is causing some pretty strong
opinions on both sides
expect a robust discussion about the
transition plan ccsd posted the 205 page
document online monday evening
since then families and educators have
been scrolling through it
and it's causing mixed reactions i think
that
this could work we have a lot of
concerns the board of trustees plan to
consider reopening campuses under a
hybrid model
that's when students attend classes in
person two days a week
and distance education the other three
days the proposal
also offers families the choice of
full-time distance education
i like the idea of them being able to
get instructions two days a week
renee parker wants her two children in a
classroom i think that
it's better for the kids she understands
the coveted risks
i've had it it's a terrible terrible
disease to have
but the cleaning protocols in the plant
give her confidence about safety in
buildings
even with the rise in positive cases in
our community
they have a good plan there is a very
big distrust that ccsd
really can have the mitigating factors
that we would need to have to keep not
just staff safe but children safe on
campus
some question the implementation if
trustees approved the recommendation
an elementary school principal notices
the divide among families attending his
school
who recently completed a survey so i
have about
200 or 240 families that have chosen the
the hybrid model and about close to 200
that have chosen the online model
choices made as the community awaits a
decision from trustees
kristen drummond 8 news now so part of
the proposal suggests that staff
returned to campus on december
1st and then students would return in
january two unions releasing statements
not in support of the timeline or even
the reopening the administrators union
calls the plan
inadequate and asked trustees to table
that decision tonight
the clark county education association
wants a koba testing program
in place before supporting any kind of a
reopening plan
so we asked you on twitter how do you
feel about opening schools
in the current pandemic climate and here
are the answers a
majority of you 66 percent say i
disagree with it you're not comfortable
with it but 34 percent say
yes they're good to go to have kids
return to the classroom